I got an email from the world champion
wingsuit team that said would you like
to learn to fly in the world's only
diagonal window I gotta start saying no
to these things my name is Jana Cordia
that's part of the wingsuit tunnel here
I've actually in setting up the coaching
here the last two years and together now
with Jenna I teach here and try to get
everybody flying currently Jenna and
myself we won last World Cup in Italy
and both indoor skydiving and outdoor
skydiving were at the moments a reining
team in wingsuit acrobatics this wind
tunnel was around since 1935 used for
testing airplanes cars and those kind of
things I think they tested the Saab
airplane and the Huygens space capsule
here this tunnel was up for auction a
few years ago and then for the local
Swedish guys who are also skydivers they
basically thought like what if we could
convert this into like an angled wind
tunnel where you could actually fly wing
suits and because that hadn't been done
yet nobody really knew if such a thing
would be possible so they bet he took
the horizontal wind tunnel here they put
a small angle tube in it once they had
done the initial testing I was called in
to actually see like besides stable
flying what else can we do in the tunnel
and when that was all like a big success
they raised the money and actually built
this amazing machine
now it's essentially an angle tube that
is on a pivot point and that can
actually rotate the tunnel up and down
with a piston I would say in terms of
physical workout for like a beginner
it's insanely heavy and that is mainly
because in the beginning you're not
flying super efficient so you're using a
lot of muscle tension you're tending to
bend the arm which creates a round wing
that really creates drag on your body in
the beginning maybe 40 minutes a day is
the max and then people really feel like
I ran three marathons I currently have
the world record which is definitely the
most boring thing I ever did but somehow
the most watched thing and it's flying
six and a half hours non-stop in the
tunnel without touching the floor walls
or anything
the last 10 seconds that you were giving
the instructions but my brain just
wasn't pausing anything what we started
with is this cable system where
essentially you're on two police that
are on this on the ceiling that allow
you to move around but they don't allow
you to actually get close to the walls
the cables definitely influence you a
little bit as well we'd like the
bounciness of cables but it's
essentially limits the motion to safely
learn to just control your body kind of
like an airplane like you lean a bit
left the wing goes left you raise the
chin and the chest gets air that changes
your angle pushes you backwards with
those kind of motions you need to really
learn to fly and even for skydivers that
have a lot of wings experienced they
tend to fly more by instinct and even
for them this is a lot more precise than
what you normally do outdoors from that
point where you can actually control
yourself on the cables there you
actually continue to flying without the
cables there's a small intermediate step
we do which is flying with a leash on
the belly which allows us to let people
fly free but in case they do anything
less smart we can still put them on the
floor the difference between flying in a
tongue and flying in the air is
definitely the the lack of space so in
the air if you're learning to fly and
you're essentially all over the place
that is not an issue in the tunnel if
you're all over the place you can be all
over the place for about two meters and
then the wall stops you another thing
that is definitely a difference is your
reflexes that you have from the grounds
like if you're flying on your back and
you're falling backwards we tend to put
our butt down to cushion our fall which
of course in the sky you would never do
and definitely the walls on the floor
they introduce these reflexes that we've
trained over the years to put your arms
in front of you or to the sides that in
flying don't have the best effect a big
thing that the tunnel brings that
skydiving doesn't get you is the amount
of training you can do and actually the
reference you get where normally in the
sky if I'm flying with a training
partner when we're having a little bit
of movement between each other we don't
see who is making the movements in the
tunnel because you have a static
reference you see every little move so
you learn so much faster because this
gives you so much more feedback in terms
of what you're doing once they show that
they can fly well with
Bella leash that comes off as well and
then you're flying fully free and then
from there it's quite a rapid
progression to learning to fly on your
back and then actually learning to do
two transitions carving around the
tunnel typically that whole progression
takes around two to three hours of
flying for most people in general it's
quite cool to see that's where normally
people would have to 300 skydives before
they could even try this now we're
taking people off the streets and
teaching them to fly in one or two days
like I could just fly through the tunnel
but they would like four or five seconds
in there where I felt stable and I don't
think you were pulling on me no no no
thank you are more than welcome super go
man
bye she's pretty good I'm done the
amount of flying in it now is what like
the super train people usually do after
like building that stamina so you flew
more than most people do on the first
day in a very short time span so they're
like all the muscles you feeling that
you've never used before it's quite
normal but you did really good and
you're gonna sleep really well together
yeah should we just turn off the life
here no because that is a slow slide
[Laughter]